if you live in Clark County unlike other
places in the country the company that
picks up your trash can actually file a
lien on homeowners who don't pay their
bill and the company Republic Services
has been doing just that and quite
frequently threatening foreclosure in
every instance tonight eight news now
investigator Kyle Payne takes the trash
company to tax
I'm just a normal person
I feel like I'm being taken advantage of
and picked on I don't know why I'd like
to know why but but for this homeowner
in Henderson why is just one of the many
questions
piling up in this trashy Tale
of the Lords of the local landfill
collecting overview fees in court almost
as automatically as a robotic trash
truck barreling down a side street I
mean I could be on the street right now
on the street instead of here at the
house she's owned for some 26 years
because one day about a month ago
Rebecca Gandara got a notice in the mail
that Republic Services the exclusive
trash collector in Clark County was
taking her to court and threatening to
foreclose saying she owes them a barrel
of money about which she says she had no
idea I never knew my bill was over ten
thousand dollars until until she went to
the district court and found out it was
true turns out Republic is suing and
threatening to foreclose on Gandara and
hundreds of other Clark County
homeowners some of whom owe as little as
three two and even just one thousand
dollars in back trash bills and state
law says they have every right to do it
and I don't think that at the time the
legislators were envisioning little old
ladies who own their homes outright
getting being threatened with
foreclosure Peter Aldous is a consumer
rights attorney with legal aid of
Southern Nevada he says Republic
Services is doing homeowners a
disservice they don't have to do this
but they do it anyway Republic Services
told the 8 news now investigators in
part quote unfortunately there are times
when customers accounts become overdue
to the point that Republic must exercise
its authority to impose a property lien
in order to ensure eventual payment for
the services rendered in 2022 Republic
went to court 323 times and another 143
already this year mostly against
homeowners who owe no more than five or
ten thousand dollars the lawyers
Williams and Starbuck work out of this
little office downtown I spoke with one
of them on the phone Donald Williams he
told me Republic still needs to pick up
the garbage regardless of whether money
is out on the bill and that his client
Republic just wants people to pay but
even if the trash bills are paid the
lawyers are still in court fighting for
their legal fees just as hard Republic
Services lawyers play hardball I saw the
public service suing me so I just went
right to the source the defendant here
representing himself in this hearing
from 2021 when Colbert forced Court
hearings to be conducted online told
judge Mark Denton that he decided to
skip over the lawyers and go right to
Republic to pay his bill but still ended
up back in court because Republic's
lawyer Drew Starbuck wanted thousands in
court costs and his legal fees all
you're seeking now is a judgment for
fees and costs correct
and his honor awarded Starbuck fifteen
hundred dollars in legal fees and
another 891 dollars in costs they just
accepted my money and that I was good I
cannot believe anything we Public
Services says and I can't believe
anything that Republic Service attorney
says Rebecca Gandara says Republic's
lawyers won't provide any proof that she
actually owes them money they won't show
me records and she says they never
served her a copy of the lawsuit I said
tell me the truth did you mail me the
summons
because I never received it so for now
Gandara representing herself has filed
an answer in court I have nine defenses
will face Republic Services
and their attorneys in front of the
Clark County Judge judges are smart
judges are fair
and like I told the attorney I will do
what the judge says and in the meantime
she'll pass on their offer to have her
debt and of course legal fees and costs
paid within a year or so and instead
she'll make sure to keep paying her
trash bill on time Kyle Payne 8 news now
other than Republic Services only
homeowners associations HOAs in the
cities and towns in Clark County have
the power to foreclose on delinquent
homeowners no other utility company or
service provider has any such clout
republics lawyers say they haven't
foreclosed on anyone as of tonight